[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Welcome, everyone.
Good evening.
My name is Jennifer Roberts.
And I am an art history
professor here at Harvard
and also Faculty Director
for the Arts at the Radcliffe
Institute.
I want to welcome you all
to the opening of our spring
exhibition, Willie
Cole, Beauties.
It's very gratifying to see
such an enthusiastic response
to this exhibition from both
within and beyond Harvard.
I'd just like to
extend a very special
welcome to the many members
of the Boston printmaking
community who are here tonight.
We're very glad to have you
here and also a very special
welcome to the group
of high school students
from RAW Art Works in Lynn, who
are also here with us tonight.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
So for those of you who haven't
been to an opening at Radcliffe
before, this is
how it will work.
I am going to deliver for
about 15 minutes along
with the introductions a quick
orientation to Cole's work
and to this exhibition.
Then Willie Cole and Cole
Rogers will be joining me up
on the stage for approximately
30 minutes of discussion.
There will not be a public
question and answer period
here in this room
mostly because we
want to get everyone
across to the gallery
to get in front of the
work as soon as possible.
So at around a
quarter or 10 to six,
we'll all adjourn, walk two
buildings down to the gallery,
and then reconvene along with
the work where we can continue
our discussions, both
amongst ourselves and also
with our guests.
So before I begin,
of course I want
to extend a few special
thanks on behalf of everyone
here at the Radcliffe Institute.
First of all, of course, I
want to thank Willie Cole
for the remarkable work that
brings us here this evening
and of course for
being here as well.
Thanks to Highpoint
Editions in Minneapolis
who've been incredibly generous
with their time and expertise
and with their prints
for this exhibition.
Thanks to everyone
who has thought
deeply about these prints with
us over the past year or so.
And many Radcliffe Fellows
and Harvard faculty and staff
have come together for
a series of discussions
over the past year,
really grappling
with the philosophical
and social meanings
of pressing in the largest and
broadest sense of the word.
And I really look
forward to having
these kinds of
conversations continuing
with the work present with
us for the next few months.
Finally, I want to thank
four graduate students in art
history and American
studies who have
worked very closely
with us on programming
and the publication--
Julia Silverman, Chassidy
Winestock, Thea Goldring,
and Chloe Chapin.
Thanks to you all.
All right, I've just been
running through the prints
to give you a quick
orientation to them.
Of course, they look
much better in person.
Cole is best known
perhaps for the links
he has forged between ironing
and domesticity embodiment,
questions of servitude,
refinement, beauty, power,
and danger.
The tools of ironing have
been central to his work
for over 30 years.
Probably his best known
work is this print, Stowage,
from 1997 in which he forged
important links between irons,
ships, and migration,
particularly
the trauma of the Middle Passage
in the Atlantic slave trade.
The infamous Brookes slave
ship diagram silently
inhabits all of his
work with ironing,
including the Beauties.
He's also developed multiple
resonances between irons
and ironing and African art--
masks, shields, scarification
practices, and sculpture.
Drawing particularly upon
Yoruba ritual traditions,
he's highlighted the
elemental associations of iron
as a metal--
so not just an appliance,
but actually an element--
invoking Ogun the Warrior
in spirit of metalwork
in Yoruba tradition, also
known as the god of iron.
At the same time, he's explored
the Christian resonances
of the iron motif, cultivating
its echoes, for example,
in the veil of the Virgin of
Guadalupe, as in this print,
as well as to Christian
liturgical vestments
and to the Gothic arch.
The Beauties which
bring us here today
absorb all of these
dense meanings
while also developing
the ironing
motif in new directions.
The Beauties were made
by stripping, crushing,
and flattening steel
ironing boards then inking
them and running them through
an etching or roller press.
This produces a powerfully
raw and immediate impression
of the flattened boards.
At the base of each of
these impressions is a name.
These names provide
a direct link
between all of
these other themes
that we've been
discussing around irons
and the labor of generations
of black women in America.
Cole's grandmother
and great grandmother
were housekeepers
who often asked
Cole to fix their steam irons
when he was a child growing up
in Newark.
The names are a testament to
the strength and persistence
of women of their
generations, as well
as a kind of tacit
recognition, I
think, that their
own work of ironing
shares a great deal with
Cole's work of printmaking.
Cole made the Beauties in
2012 at the Highpoint Center
for Printmaking in Minneapolis.
In collaboration
with Cole Rogers
and the other expert printers
in the professional studio
there, he developed a unique
process for this very unusual
printmaking challenge.
Now the first and inescapable
thing to say about this process
is that it was a violent one.
You can't just put an ironing
board through a printing press
as is.
First you have to flatten it.
Cole and the printers
did this first
with hammers, sledges,
and concrete blocks,
a process which both
crushed the boards
and marked them with various
patterns of impact markings.
As Cole said, "We
destroyed them.
We surfed them down hills
and hammered them out.
We even ran trucks
over them to give them
a little more history.
I think of them as
ironing board warriors."
Then they were put
through the roller press
multiple times without
ink to be flattened
further until they were down to
just a few millimeters thick.
Then they were
inked and printed.
Each time through
the press, something
on the order of 45,000
pounds of pressure
was distributed
along that line where
the roller meets the board.
Now, when we confront
the intensity,
the power of this
process and its violence,
it's tempting to see this
simply as a kind of diminution,
a sort of violent
reduction of the boards
and all that they
might represent,
crushing them into the tiniest
possible space, silencing them
as if dominating them.
But something happens as the
prints emerge from the press,
from that intense process.
They unfold in a sense.
They expand both perceptually
and conceptually.
Despite the harsh forces at
the heart of their making,
they come to have something
like a regal bearing, a quality
of strength, a sense of
expansive and even luminous
transparency.
And we get a sense
of this, I think,
in the profusion
of different kinds
of often contradictory
associations that
come to settle on the boards
when you come and see them.
So some of these
associations, yes, do
speak about trauma and
violence, death even.
So the boards look
like slave ships,
like tombstones, like
shrouds, like mummies.
But other associations
also shoulder their way
into this scene with different
and even contradictory kinds
of valences.
So they also look like
stained glass windows,
like shields, veils,
bolts of patterned fabric,
sentinels, guardians,
saints, even surfboards.
The prints rapidly oscillate
between associations
of violence and beauty and
precariousness and permanence
and matter and spirit.
It's as if the intense
pressure of that printing press
has somehow taken a set
of cultural binaries
and oppositions and sealed
them together so that they
can no longer be separated,
so they constantly
inhabit each other.
So let's look, for
example, at just one
example of that kind
of collapsed binary
that we see happening
in these prints.
The Beauties managed to imply,
for example, both a horizontal
and a vertical posture
at the same time.
When you look at
them on the wall,
as you'll see in
the gallery, they
have a kind of dignified
verticality about them.
They resemble royal or
aristocratic portraits.
So Queen here on
the left really does
tap into a very long history
of aristocratic, full-length
portraiture in the west.
But it's never quite
possible, of course,
to forget that these were
made prone on the press beds,
subject to a drama of
crushing pressure and counter
pressure, a stress
position as it
were, something that's totally
different from any kind
of airy, easy, blithe
standing position
so that when the beauties
are hung on the wall
then, when they return to
this vertical position,
their origins in the press
really accompany them
to the wall, charge them with
what I see as a kind of air
of endurance and resistance.
So in other words, they
don't just stand there.
They do something more complex.
They withstand.
You can say the same about
innumerable other oppositions
that these prints
collapse together,
so let's say destruction
and creation.
Let's think about the hammering
away at these ironing boards
out in the parking lot
of Highpoint Editions
in Minneapolis.
This seems like it's all about
destruction and violence.
But it also echoes something
that has been important to Cole
from the outset, the ancient
histories of metal working
in multiple cultures, where
you have the hammering
of blacksmiths, the hammering of
metal and chasing and repoussé
processes in
decorative metalwork.
Seen this way, the same
process of hammering
invokes then both destruction
and creation, ornament, beauty,
and even protection.
So I could go on with
these collapsed binaries.
We could talk about transparency
and opacity, presence
and absence, memory
and oblivion.
In each case, what's
remarkable about these prints,
I think, is that
they manage to effect
a constantly switching
circuit of energy and value.
They created a certain
kind of reversibility
in the vectors of power
that run through them.
And I want to close these
short remarks by pointing out
that this reversibility
extends very deeply
into the heart of this
project to the very role
and position of the women who
are named in these prints.
We're meant to see the
Beauties as portraits of women.
The names are like titles.
And we see the boards as
representing the women
to whom they refer.
So we might naturally
envision a print like Sapphire
here on the left as a picture
of a woman, perhaps a woman
like the woman on the
right, who was captured
at the turn of the 20th century
in a documentary photograph
from the Hampton
School where she was
being trained as a domestic.
But does this board really
represent Sapphire, picture
her, stand in for her?
I think not only, not
entirely, and not necessarily.
Let's imagine the
following scenario.
Sapphire is ironing
a dress shirt
for the white man for whom she
goes on to work as a domestic.
She places the wrinkled shirt
on the board and begins.
At this point, whom does
that ironing board represent?
Here in the actual
scene of pressing,
for whom does that
ironing board stand?
Of course, then it doesn't
stand for Sapphire.
It doesn't stand for her
body, but for the body
of her employer, the body
that will wear that shirt.
In this case, he comes
from the Nordstrom website.
The board's neck stands for
his neck or arms or shoulders,
its back for his back
or chest or side.
From this perspective, Sapphire
is not the ironing board.
She's more like the artist
working upon the board,
wielding the creative
and dangerous powers
of heat and pressure.
And in fact, her work with the
iron is a lot like printmaking.
She transforms material
through pressure,
moving fluidly between
two and three dimensions.
As she folds the shirt, turns
it inside out, and presses,
she develops a really
keen understanding
of reversal and
inversion, symmetry.
All of these are very typical
as well of printmaking.
So Sapphire's name at
the bottom of her print
may seem to function as a title.
But it is also, I
think, a signature.
Sapphire is not just the
printed, but the printer;
not just a figure, but
a figurative artist.
These prints, I think,
represent not just
the sufferance of these women,
but also their knowledge
and their creativity
and their power.
If I've done
anything here, I hope
it is to suggest that
these prints ultimately
refuse any kind of single
or simple interpretations.
They require a lot of time.
And they also require a whole
community of interpreters.
And this is what we've set out
to enable in this exhibition
here at the Radcliffe Institute.
The Radcliffe Institute is an
institute for advanced study.
But I also like to think of it
as an institute for advancing
study, for opening
up discussion,
for raising questions that
have not yet been answered,
and especially for seeding new
kinds of questions and research
among students and community
members at Harvard and beyond.
We do this in several
different ways.
And several of them are
going to be active here
through the next couple of
months in this exhibition.
First of all, we have
what we call a gallery
series for which
we invite faculty,
staff, and students to
produce performances,
lectures, readings in the
gallery responding to the work
from all of their many
different disciplinary angles.
We'll have nearly one of
these events every week
for the next few months.
And there is somewhere--
I have a list of these events.
You can check in the gallery.
We will have this list.
It's also on the gallery
website, OnViewAtRadcliffe.org.
And you can get a sense of
the different events that
will be happening.
We'll have everything
from a discussion
with a South African artist
to a dance performance
by HipHopEx director,
Aysha Upchurch.
So again, see the site for the
many different gallery events
that we'll be having.
We also encourage extensive
curricular engagement
with the work.
We have several classes
coming through the gallery.
If you are a professor
or a teacher locally
and you'd like to bring your
class, please let us know.
We are very eager to
have as many classes
come through this
gallery as possible.
We've also created a
resource that we're
happy to distribute to anyone
who's interested that includes
a set of primary
sources, materials
here at Harvard and the
various different collections
that students might
use in their research,
so everything from a book
at the Schlesinger Library
titled A Man's Shirt is a
Woman's Problem to African art
objects at the Peabody
Museum, prints and drawings
at the Harvard Art Museums.
So please contact us
if you are interested.
And you can go, again,
to OnViewAtRadcliffe.org.
Also, we have our booklet
which is available for free
in the gallery.
You'll all be getting one
by the end of the evening.
And this includes
an essay that goes
into a great deal of detail
about how the prints were made.
OK, so now let me
get to the good part.
Let me introduce our guests.
Of course, in a sense I've
already introduced Willie Cole.
But here is some further
information about him.
He is, of course, a world
renowned print maker, but also
a sculptor.
He studied here in
these parts originally
at the Boston University
College of Fine Arts.
He also studied at the
School of Visual Arts
in New York and the Art
Students League of New York.
His honors include the
David C. Driskell Prize,
the Saint-Gaudens Fellowship, a
Joan Mitchell Foundation grant,
and an artist residency at
the Studio Museum in Harlem.
His work has been
exhibited and collected
by institutions
around the world,
including the British
Museum, the Museum of Modern
Art, the Newark Museum,
the St. Louis Art
Museum, and many more.
And he lives and works
in Mine Hill, New Jersey.
I'm also very happy
to welcome tonight
Cole Rogers, who is the
artistic director and master
printer at Highpoint
Editions in Minneapolis.
He invited Willie Cole to
produce work at the studio
and collaborated with him on
the conception and development
of the Beauties.
He spent many years as the print
shop director and printmaking
coordinator at the Minneapolis
College of Art and Design
where he taught and
shaped curriculum.
Previously, he was
a senior printer
at the legendary Tamarind
Institute in New Mexico.
He earned his BFA in printmaking
from the University of Alabama
at Birmingham, an MFA in
printmaking from Ohio State
University, and a Master Printer
Certificate from the Tamarind
Institute in Albuquerque.
Please join me in welcoming
Willie Cole and Cole
Rogers to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
- Don't look.
- OK, so let's get the
complicated question
of names out of the way.
We have Willie Cole
and Cole Rogers.
So I'm just going to stick--
we're going to do this
on a first name basis,
if that's all right with you.
So you'll be Willie
and you'll be Cole.
- Actually, my first
name is Willis.
- Is it really?
- Yes.
- Really?
- Cole is my middle name.
- OK, let's not even.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's not even get there.
So I'm really happy to have
both of you here this evening,
because I think it's really
important that we think
about the Beauties as prints.
I think it's very
important to recognize
the importance of the print
making process to this project.
And I've been thinking, would
these work in any other medium?
Would they work as
photographs or painting
or even as ready made
battered ironing boards?
And I don't think that they
would, because in so many ways,
the making of these works,
this application of pressure
really ties into all of these
cognates around pressure
and oppression that are so
much part of this project.
So it's really a thrill to
have you both here so that we
can focus on these questions.
I want to begin with a
question first for you, Willie,
having to do with the
naming of the prints.
And I'm just going to
read the names of all 28
of these prints--
Anna Mae, Bertha Mae, Bessie,
Calpurnia, Carolina, Clara
Esther, Dot, Emma, Eva Mae,
Fannie Mae, Ida Mae, Jane,
Jesse Mae, Jonny Mae, Lily,
Lucy, Lulabelle, Mammy, Matti
Lee, Pearl, Queen, Rose, Ruth,
Sapphire, Sarah, Savannah,
Willy Mae, and Zetty.
Can you talk us through
the naming of these prints,
what these names
mean to you, and why
you felt that they should
be attached to these prints?
- Yes.
Upon viewing these boards,
when you look at a work of art,
it talks to you.
You don't want to think
you know everything when
you're making a work of art.
So the boards told me
what they were about.
And one thing that stood
out in our conversation
was that they were about
women who have labored,
women who have suffered,
women in my family.
So I went through.
I've known my family--
in my lifetime, I
have experienced
five or six generations.
I knew my great grandmother
and my great-great grandmother
and of course all their friends.
So the names come from
that group of women.
The second part of
the question was--
- That was the whole question.
Yeah, I mean, I have
some other parts to it.
Did you look at the
prints and then name them
based on some qualities
of the prints or--
- No.
- --was it more--
- I didn't.
- --accidental?
- I didn't, because
I'm very into jazz
and just you know the song.
But when your solo
comes, you don't
want to play the melody again.
So I just mixed it
all up and had faith
that it was going to work out.
- Great, great.
And some of them are names
of people in your family.
But as I understand,
some are actually
not necessarily associated
with specific people.
- Right.
Most are family or
friends of family.
But there's some that
are just of that era,
of the era of my
great grandmother
where everybody had those
names with Mae on the end
or some had Bible names,
like Ruth, et cetera.
- And some named
after places, right?
- Yeah, so you know a lot.
Two are places.
The two places would
be my mother's family
being from Georgia--
Savannah, Georgia--
and my father's family
being from North Carolina.
So one board is Carolina.
Another one is Savannah.
- Cole, maybe you
could talk a little bit
about what it took to get
the names on the paper,
because they weren't
printed at the same time,
as I understand
it, as the boards.
- That was a fairly
simple process.
But I think-- it was just what's
called relief printing where
we basically printed some type
that was printed at the end
after the printing process.
But I think it was a
little bit more interesting
trying to figure
out how to do it
as far as what technique,
because we do use the four
different media and whether or
not it was going to be a screen
print that sat on top or whether
or not it was going to be
pressed into the paper the same
way that the rest of the image
was or how that
would be printed.
And after playing around
a little bit, which
is pretty much so what we
did even at the beginning
before the boards
were started-- we
were playing with some
different processes.
And we came up with using type.
And anybody that
does letter press
is familiar with the idea of
the kiss impression, which
is a very light impression,
which just touches the paper.
And it reads fully,
but it doesn't indent.
It doesn't go into the
paper in the same way
that the rest of the image did.
And it was just-- it seemed
like a very poetic way
of naming these women
after the intaglio section.
The rest of the section was kind
of their rough life and kind
of the weathered
bit of the intaglio.
- No, I think it's
especially interesting
the way the prints come into
the studio violently in essence,
but they leave with
this kiss impression.
And the name sits
lightly on the paper.
Can you both, I wonder,
talk a little bit
about your
collaborative process?
How were these made?
How did you collaborate?
How did you see your
individual roles?
Many people may not be fully
familiar with how important
the process of collaboration
is in creating a print
project like this.
- Well, I'm not a master
of print making techniques.
I always feel honored when
people say I'm a print maker.
I had a chance to be a keynote
speaker at a print conference.
And the only way I could do
that and feel good about it
was to acknowledge all the
print makers who helped me out
over the years.
And this is actually my
favorite print maker.
So the collaboration is
an act of submission.
Let the ego go.
Don't think you know everything.
And be eager to learn, to
witness, and to assist.
So I was a big fan of the shop
and just glad to be there.
My history included the iron
as an icon or as an image.
So that's what I brought
to the collaboration.
If I remember correctly,
Cole's what he called play
with the ironing board helped
to reveal what was possible.
And from there, we just
tried to stay in the mix.
And of course, you
don't know what
it's going to look
like until the end,
even though you think you do.
Once we saw that,
I felt and I knew--
had a better sense of
where we were going.
But it wasn't until I
saw them all on the wall
that they really
began to talk to me.
And even today they've
revealed things
to me they didn't reveal before,
like really emotional stuff
that I hadn't touched on before.
- How about you, Cole?
- I think the role of a
really good collaborator
in my position who's basically
a technician is to stay out
of the way, to know when
to get in there and guide,
but also that the reins need to
be in the hands of the artist,
that you hand off things.
It needs to be very much
so the artist experience
with the materials that
leads you to the end,
that you can start out
with too rigid of an idea
or you have a printer
who's very rigid
and wants to limit
the artist and wants
to make everything easy.
And they're trying to figure
out things really early.
And you really need to kind of
let things blow up at first.
If everything that
you try is a success,
you're not trying hard enough.
Your research is not really
pushing the envelope.
And so it's pretty much
though getting in there
and giving your artist
options, seeing what develops,
and trying to stay
out of the way
and letting the project
develop along its own line.
We tried etching
lithography, wood cut,
screen printing at the beginning
just to get our feet wet.
And the project revealed
itself on its own.
- Can you take us into a little
bit more detail about some
of the blow-ups or failures?
What were you imagining
you would do when you--
- Well, it was--
- --arrived?
- --a compositional evolution,
because I had done a scorch--
not a scorch, but an
ironing board previously.
They've represented
exclusively a ship.
My concept coming
into the studio
was to make the port where
all the ships had come in.
- Oh wow.
So it really was a--
- So it evolved.
- --ship project at first.
- Yes, yes.
- Interesting.
And so how did it turn from
ships to all the things
that they are now?
- Seeing a single image
by itself was enough.
You didn't need to have,
like, 40 ships docked
in a pool of water.
That's illustration.
To me, that's the big
challenge in fine art today
is I know it's changed a bit.
But I still make a distinction
between illustration
in fine art.
But a lot of fine art nowadays
is illustration to me.
So this became fine
art at the moment
that we were to
isolate, take them out
of the imagined scenario,
come up with a story.
But that's like coming
in and closing the door.
You want to walk in the room
and leave the door open.
Let other stuff come in.
Let some breeze blow
and all that stuff.
That's what it was for me.
- Well, the initial
attempts at printing off
of an ironing board, really
didn't know if it would work.
And it was pretty beautiful.
So we went out and
sourced as many as we
could find from the Goodwill
and other secondhand stores.
And we were only able
to find a handful.
And Willie ran out of time.
We'd tried the lithograph and
wood cut and other things.
And so we sourced
more, flattened them.
And so when Willie came
back and saw the individuals
lining the studio for him
to choose which ones to use,
it just developed on its own.
All of a sudden,
the initial idea,
while wonderful and may
return to it one day,
was kind of secondary.
- Yeah, yeah.
You had mentioned when we
were talking back in November
that originally you'd gone
to Home Depot or something
to get the boards there and
found that all ironing boards
that you can buy today now
have the same exact structure
and patterns of the
steam holes and so forth.
And so it was actually a
huge project going around
to thrift shops
and Craigslist just
to get a set of
vintage ironing boards.
So that's something
to think about too,
that all of these
prints come from ironing
boards that have already a
long history of domestic work.
Someone has ironed
on these boards.
So there's all of that memory
in the metal as well, I think.
And one of the
interesting things
that I find about print
residencies like this
is that you don't always
fly out to Minneapolis
and stay there for two
weeks and then finish
everything and leave.
In this case, you
went three times?
Twice?
- Yeah, that's--
- Think so.
- He remembers it better.
- So there's a rhythm
where you're working
and then you have a long
period away from the studio.
What was that like?
Were you able-- were you
thinking about the process
while doing your other work?
Did you feel that
this on and off moment
for work and contemplation
affected your project?
- Well, I think that walking
away from a work of art--
and you know, I'm
on two tracks now.
Like, I'm at a point
in my life where
nothing makes sense anymore.
I'm redefining--
maybe I am re-creating
the future I imagined
for myself as an artist.
But I'm expected to be in
the present that was my past.
So it's kind of a confusing
place that I'm in right now.
But walking away
from these pieces
and coming back weeks
later was a good thing,
because it took me away
from my projected narrative
and allowed me what they call
fresh eyes to see it new.
Most of the time-- like, I have
some paintings in my studio
now that I started.
And then I had to
go away for a month.
When I came back, it was
like starting all over again.
I hadn't been able to finish
them, so just start them over
again.
But fortunately in
this case, the fire
was still turned up, even
though I wasn't in the kitchen.
So they just kept cooking.
And they made it.
- That's right.
And what are you doing when
Willie's not in the studio?
- Well, we usually have
three to four artists a year
that come in.
And so we juggle a lot
of different projects.
And ours is not a residency
that's a set length of time.
Early on, I became really
frustrated with a lot
of the studios I was working
in that had set residencies.
So to invite an artist
out for two weeks--
all your artists, two weeks--
is an artificial limitation
from the beginning.
And what if one more week is
going to turn a project around?
Or maybe the artist only
needs a certain amount
of time working
and then to go back
and there could be
a gestation period
and then come back
and bring that.
And the idea of having
these set residencies
doesn't make a lot of sense.
So I think it's problematic
for us scheduling.
Our calendar is
constantly in turmoil.
But I think it's really
important that an artist does
get a chance to back away,
that there's not this two weeks
and you've got to be
signing the [? BET, ?]
which is very
common in most shops
that you have to have this
set, or maybe it's not cooked
or maybe it needs
to be thrown away.
Maybe it needs to
be started again.
So I think it's helpful
when an artist gets a chance
to look at it.
And we go back to
other projects.
And we're printing and
doing other editioning
while we're waiting for
Willie to come back.
And we've gotten a
little bit of distance.
All of a sudden, we can
come back to a piece.
And we weren't under
a time constraint.
And we say, we could
do this differently
or we could do this better.
And so I think it's really
helpful to have those breaks.
- And that approach gave
me a lot of freedom,
not just physical but
emotional and spiritual,
because this is all about women.
I was raised to be polite
and not to take too much.
So it's like, you mean
if the first one didn't
work we could try it again?
So that was all beautiful.
That took a lot of
pressure off me as a human.
- That's terrific.
So these have-- really,
this is the first time
that the set of Beauties
have been shown together
since they were made.
They were made in 2012.
And they were shown in
the gallery at Highpoint
in Minneapolis at that
time of their making.
But this is the first time
they've all been back together.
It's the first time
you've seen them
on the walls since that moment.
And I just wonder--
you mentioned that you're
seeing new things in them,
that you're responding
differently to them now.
I wonder if maybe
both of you could
talk a little bit about how
they've changed since 2012.
A lot of things have
happened since 2012.
On my part, I felt that
it was important to bring
these particular
prints together now.
They seem incredibly present
and urgent at the moment,
perhaps prescient in 2012.
- I hate to begin sentences
with I think and I feel,
because those are not facts.
Those are feelings.
But I can't help it right now
and say that in the first round
when they were
exhibited at Highpoint,
because I had the history of
connecting Africa to irons
and ironing boards.
And it was-- all of my feelings
and thoughts were outside
of my personal experience.
I had already been branded
Willie the Scorch in the art
world.
So it was just me
doing my thing.
But I guess as years went on
and maybe I became more open
in myself, I began to make
more personal associations
that I didn't make initially.
And I don't know if--
everybody-- you
process information
through your own filters.
But I think I just became
more open to my own filters
and have been able to
see them in a much more
emotional and visceral
way than I did initially.
And they hit me
hard the first time
I saw them when we
first created them.
But today you all are lucky
I'm not sitting here crying.
Maybe I'm lucky.
- It's OK to cry in the gallery.
I'll just say that.
It's already happened
today a few times.
So-- how about you, Cole?
- The first time
that we showed them,
we showed them in a
very different context
and a very different lighting.
And I just thought that
they were the greatest
things in the world.
And then I see them here and
there as we've sold them.
And we've shown five at
a time here and there.
But all of a sudden
seeing them again,
it was like a family reunion.
It was like-- there's something
different about the context,
being able to see all of
them and reconnecting.
It's kind of--
sounds sappy, but it
is much like family,
somebody that you're
very close to that you
don't see for a long time
and then you see in the context
of a group or a community.
It's great to see them again.
- Just seeing, as
an artist, work
from the past, even
the recent past,
is kind of like reconnecting
with your children
or your family.
I often feel removed from
the work once it's gone.
So it's a big reunion, as he
stated, when you see it again.
You don't know if the work has
matured or you have matured.
But you see it and feel it
differently, at least I do.
- I think it's very interesting
the way the word family
is being used to
refer to these prints,
because you wouldn't normally
think about printmaking, which
is understood usually as this
simple process of copying
or reproduction or
seriality, as being something
that has quite such a sense of
personality and individuality.
But these, I think, really
mediate between their role
as parts of a set,
parts of a series.
You walk into the gallery.
It's all ironing boards.
They're all about the same size.
They're all made pretty
much the same way.
So you have a very strong sense
of their serial production.
And yet each is profoundly
individualized and
individuated.
And so I think the family is--
- Just like us.
We're all the same.
- Yeah, I mean the family,
I think, makes sense.
- But we're uniquely--
- It's a series of
individuals that are related.
But yet we actually are only
able to show 24 of the 28
in the gallery, because
that's all the room we had.
So I went out to
Minneapolis in November
and had to decide which four
would not be in the show.
And it felt like cutting
people from a team.
It felt deeply personal.
So there are four that are not
actually in the exhibition.
But you get a good
sense of the seriality
and the full set of these
prints when you walk in there.
And I should also mention that
after this exhibition closes
in June, you'll still be able
to see some of the prints
on the Harvard campus, because
the Harvard Art Museums owns
five of the prints.
So you can always
reconnect with them,
study them, work with them even
beyond the run of this show
just by going to the
Harvard Art Museums
and asking to see them
in the study center.
So they will remain available.
I just have one more
question and then
we can move to the gallery,
and that is, Willie,
you've talked about
your previous work
and looking back on work that
you're not actively involved
in at the moment.
At the moment, you have been
working very intensively
around ecological
concerns and questions.
You've done a lot of work
with plastic water bottles,
the ubiquitous environmental
scourge of our age
where you're transforming them
in much the same way you've
transformed these prints.
And I wonder if you
see any connection
between your previous
work around ironing
and this new work that has
to do with the flow of water
and the different
kinds of elements.
- Yes.
Well, my interests
or my habit is
to work with objects that
have had intimate contact
with human beings.
I believe those
things that Einstein
said about wherever you go,
you leave yourself there,
because 99% of dust
in your house is you.
And you're not a stagnant
collection of particles.
You're a living
So the things you touch
hold onto part of you.
So my interest then is
to extract or reveal
the spirit in any object I use.
And there's no technique
for that other than--
I guess actually the technique
for that is a desire to do it.
And the desire to do it
informs you when it's done,
because you see it.
So the water bottle
to me is even
a more obvious vehicle of human
energy, like say the bottle
itself is like--
a water bottle is
basically life in a coffin.
It's like the
thing that gives us
life is being transported to
us in the thing that gives us
death.
- Right.
So right off the bat, there's
this kind of similarity
in the way the binaries work.
Exactly.
- But they have this
spiritual connection to me.
- Yes, that's great.
All right, I think we
should let everyone get in
to see the works themselves.
Remind you, we're not going
to do question and answer now.
We're not going to be
doing any milling about.
We're going to try to have this
be a transition where everyone
can get over to the gallery.
And then you'll be able to ask
any further questions of Cole
and Willie when we get there.
But for now, please
join me in thanking them
for this discussion.
[APPLAUSE]